foreign
[Music]
yes you do with a superhero power of
survival tonight Wynonna carries on the
legacy of her late mother Naomi when she
takes the stage solo for the Jets the
final tour
so how are you feeling now getting back
into hitting the road again I'm in the
middle of feeling both
like the pressure's off and yet this is
it because once this is done this is a
chapter closed so there's a lot of
crying and praying and a lot of
gratitude a lot of grief and it's all
happening
simultaneously at times it's been one of
the toughest things I've ever done and
it was necessary to move on
during the tour one owner will welcome
some girl power special guests including
Ashley McBride Brandy Carlisle Kelsey
ballerini and Martina McBride what are
your pre-show rituals I have my dogs you
have your pigs not yet I don't know how
in the world we're going to work it out
Juanita
this is what I do every day
[Applause]
so maybe not the pigs who I met on
Winona's Tennessee farm in 2021 but she
will bring along husband of 10 years
Cactus who is in the band
I saw the band warming up Cactus is
ready to hit the road he was scrubbing
up he is a drummer and he does things
loudly and boldly it's like a wedding
for Cactus and me he literally walks me
up the aisle I'm closer to my husband
than I've ever been there's something
about being on the road that's the
greatest Most Holy moment for me on
stage singing from my toenails and
sharing that with people knowing it's
helping them
booyah
[Music]
foreign